في مقر قطب مكافحه الارهاب لا تنتهي جلسه
استنطاق للمتهمين في قضيه التامر على امن
الدوله حتى تبدا اخرى وعمليات الايداع
بالسجن تتوالى لاول مره في قضيه بهذا
الحجم القضاء يستعد عافيته هكذا يؤكد
المتابعون للملف
وقضى التحقيق في القطب الذين اصدر
البطاقات هذوما في زمن
البحيري ما كانش بالامكان انه ربما حتى
الملف ما يتعداش للنيابه بتاتا
من الدليل على ذلك ان هذه المعنى هناك
جرائم او ابحاث هناك ملفات الان على رفوف
ما كانت على رفوف معناها في وزاره العدل
ولا في الحكومه خرجت الى النور واصبح
البحث فيها عن عجائز من الناحيه الاجرائيه
ومن ناحيه القانونيه المعارضه على راسها
جبهه الخلاص بقياده النهضه تهدد بالنزول
الى الشارع بينما الرئيس قيس سعيد ماض في
مشروعه لانقاذ البلاد كما يقول
القضيه تتفرع الى ملفات اخرى منها الارهاب
والفساد اليوم رئيس الجمهوريه يتقدم بخ
طاحه مشروع سياسي والشعاره في المحاسبه
ايضا القضاء دخل على الخط بقوه لكن يبقى
ربما التحدي هو اناره الراي العام وتقديم
الروايه التي تدعم ما يحدث اليوم في تونس
مع دخول الاقافاته في قضيه التامر على امن
الدوله الاسبوع الثالث تلوح المعارضه
بالنزول الى شارع معتبره القضيه مفبركه
بينما يؤكد مساندون الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
انها تمثل بدايه التعافي الفعلي للقضاء في
مواجهه ثالوث الارهاب والفساد والتامر على
امن الدوله اما الشارع فلسان حاله يقول لا
احد فوق القانون مستقبلا ولابد من
المحاسبه وكشف الحقيقه للراي العام
المحاسبه كانت حلم ينتظر التونسي الكل
والغرف المظلمه طلعت بالحق غرف مظلمه
واجتماعات بعد نص الليل وهذه اشياء يعني
ثابته جدا اكبر من الدوله ما ثم حتى حد
فوق القانون وتؤكد مصادر قانونيه ان دائره
الاتهامات والاحكام بالسجن ستشمل العشرات
مستقبلا مع تقدم التحقيقات في واحده من
اخطر القضايا منذ سقوط نظام الرئيس الاسبق
زين العابدين بن علي وليد عبد الله
العربيه تونس